Десятки завдань, консультацій і рух нон-стоп.
Це - типовий робочий день Германа, ветерана російсько-української війни.
Колись він був слюсарем, а нині працює в реабілітаційному центрі для поранених захисників.
Я працюю спеціалістом першого контакту. Мої задачі такі: я зустрічаю пацієнтів, розказую їм про центр.
Якщо треба, проводжу екскурсію, проводжу до лікарів.
Якщо виникають якісь питання у хлопців по документах, чи які з частини треба взяти,
чи які в соцзахист треба віднести, чи у пенсійний фонд - я з тим всім можу їм допомогти й розказати.
Адже сам пройшов увесь цей шлях. Герман мобілізувався в перші дні повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну,
а в грудні 2022-го отримав поранення.
Треба було затягнути побратима в окоп, йому ногу відірвало.
Я виліз і наступний снаряд уже був мій.
То був танковий снаряд, пару метрів від мене розірвався.
Мені сказали, що дуже пощастило, що ще так легко відбувся.
Зазвичай, каже, від таких прильотів розрізає навпіл.
Далі - шість операцій, протезування й тривала реабілітація.
Ще на етапі відновлення Герман почав думав про пошук роботи, але згодом вона його знайшла сама.
В планах, як не армія, то я собі думав чи таксистом стати, за кермом я можу їздити спокійно.
То я думав водієм стати чи торговим представником.
А так вийшло, що мені тут запропонували.
Воно мені якраз до душі лежить.
Мені робота в кайф. Я приходжу, я хочу сюди йти.
Нема такого, як зазвичай, коли йдеш на роботу й ніби тягнеш за собою кайданки.
Також Герман допомагає пораненим захисникам знайти себе у спорті
й супроводжує їх на різноманітних змаганнях.
Кубки вдалося взяти з легкої атлетики.
Тут біг на 100 м, на 400 м. Ну, якось так старались й щось вийшло в нас.
Свою історію Герман розповідає DW,
аби власним прикладом надихнути інших ветеранів жити й працювати.
Якщо плакати, то що? Воно ж не відросте. Тут немає такої історії, як у ящірки з хвостом.
Не хочеться вішати носа, треба власним прикладом хлопцям показувати,
що на тому життя не зупинилося й можна далі розвиватися та займатися улюбленими справами.
І ці слова Германа насправді важливі,
адже більшість українських ветеранів у питанні пошуку роботи налаштовані песимістично.
Про це свідчать результати соціологічного дослідження,
яке було проведено Українським ветеранським фондом з вересня по жовтень 2023 року.
Понад 80% опитаних припускають, що не зможуть знайти роботи.
Коли ми опитали по онлайн-опитуванню.
Ми розповсюджували форму через ЗСУ та інші структури сил оборони,
то загалом 20% з тих ветеранів, які наразі вже демобілізовані,
вони шукають роботу й не можуть знайти.
Ще найбільша проблема, яку вбачають військові
- це те, що після повернення в них буде проблема з працевлаштуванням.
Адже ветерани, які до мобілізації обіймали найрізноманітніші посади,
після звільнення зі служби мають значно менший вибір на ринку праці.
Це люди, які працювали в ІТ, в дизайні.
Це люди, які мали свій бізнес.
Це люди досить високого профілю.
І тому, коли вони повертаються й бачать пропозиції на ринку праці такого рівня,
то більше 60% говорять, що будуть робити власну справу.
І хоча офіційна інформація про кількість ветеранів в країні відсутня,
за словами рекрутерів, нині на ринку праці їх від чотирьохсот до шестисот тисяч.
Йдеться про ветеранів, які брали участь як у бойових діях під час повномасштабної війни,
так і за часів АТО та ООС.
Не можна узагальнювати статус ветерана на ринку праці.
Потрібно розділити ветеранів на певні категорії: це ветерани з інвалідністю, ветерани, які не мають обмежень по стану здоров'я.
Це ветерани різного віку,
різної кваліфікації й відповідно кожен із них знаходиться на різному етапі
своєї соціальної адаптації після завершення служби.
І хтось умовно готовий шукати роботу наступного дня після демобілізації,
а хтось потребує фізичної та психологічної адаптації.
На це може піти рік-два.
Утім, саме для ветеранів з інвалідністю пошук роботи особливо ускладнено.
Якщо деталізувати рівень готовності роботодавців до працевлаштування ветеранів з інвалідністю,
то український бізнес, українське суспільство ще на етапі підготовки до цього.
Компанія, роботодавець повинні ще адаптувати умови,
середовище для того, щоб людина могла реалізувати свій потенціал
і виконувати свої робочі обов'язки враховуючи свої особливості.
І все це про дуже персональний підхід.
І хоча дедалі більше українських роботодавців висловлюють
бажання працевлаштувати ветеранів, лише самого бажання замало,
пояснюють в Українському ветеранському фонді.
Ринок праці дуже сильно зміниться, тому що зараз підприємці запитують самі:
"Ми хочемо взяти ветерана на роботу". Але треба йому ще щось і запропонувати.
Йому необхідно запропонувати конкурентні умови працевлаштування.
Однак, як бачимо, на жаль, по факту роботодавці не дуже на це звертають увагу.
Нині особливо відкриті до ветеранів в IT.
Ця сфера дає можливість працювати з мінімальною фізичною активністю й водночас отримувати конкуренту зарплату.
У нас зараз понад 250 людей воює, 50 вже повернулися.
Більшість - це ті, які пішли з нашої компанії й повернулися.
Проте є люди, які повернулися з війни й до війни не були нашими працівниками.
І ми їх взяли на роботу. Працюють на різних посадах: починаючи з охоронців і закінчуючи керівниками відділів.
Компанії, які працевлаштовують ветеранів,
намагаються власним прикладом спростовувати упередження щодо демобілізованих.
Ба більше - вбачають в наявності бойового досвіду переваги.
З одного боку, воюючи, вони, можливо, втрачають певні знання,
а з іншого боку - здобувають певний досвід.
Лідерський досвід, якого важко здобути в цивільному житті.
Тому ми намагаємося використовувати сильні сторони.
А якщо треба довчати чи перевчати, то ми це робимо.
Проте такі історії - радше виняток, адже працевлаштування ветеранів,
зокрема й з інвалідністю - шлях, яким Україна лише починає йти.
Тож навіть реабілітаційні центри для військових, розуміючи всі труднощі,
наймають на роботу своїх колишніх пацієнтів.
Приміром, у центрі протезування Superhumans працюють двоє протезованих водіїв,
а також п’ятеро фахівців першого контакту, серед яких і Герман.
Ми позиціонуємо наш центр не лікарнею, а центром втрачених можливостей.
І тому з цього виникла ідея з працевлаштуванням, з наданням можливостей розвитку чи навчання.
Ми не тільки надаємо протези для відновлення фізичної спроможності самообслуговування й пересування,
а й для відкриття потенціалу й становлення себе як особистості.
Як каже сам Герман, нині він проживає найбільш насичений та яскравий період життя.
І багато в чому завдячує саме улюбленій роботі.
Утім, нині має ще один привід для того, аби почуватися щасливим.
Дружина Германа при надії.
Скоро стану татусем. Татулічком.
Першу ми очікуємо дівчинку.